[Music]
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know our Bible question and answer
program and we are so glad that you
chose to join us this this day for one
of our favorite programs here uh at
secret unsealed and Su TV my name is CA
Murray I'm in the company of Pastor
David Salazar and Pastor Steven bour
gentlemen good to have you here thank
you Pastor always a pleasure we we like
studying the word of God together and we
like to have an excuse to study the word
of God I guess we don't really need an
excuse but this program does give us an
excuse to do what we love to do and
that's study the word of God Amen and to
hear your questions because it lets us
know as Ministry how we can be of
assistance to your walk with the Lord
and what we can do to improve your
relationship with the Lord by answering
those questions that you have on your
heart so thank you in advance for the
questions that you are sending should
you want to ask a question we invite you
to write to
TV sutv Su
mv.org that is tv. tv.org and we will
get to your questions just as soon as we
can we got some good news today that we
are sort of keeping up with the pile
praise the Lord amen that it's not as
long as it once was so that means that
we're doing a good job and uh we thank
you keep on sending your questions
because your questions makes this
program possible so uh don't forget send
them and uh if you would please let us
know where you are writing from if that
is not too much of a bother because it
lets us know uh where our reaches and
how we can as it were scratch where you
itch and do what the Lord has called us
to do and that is bring you answers from
the word of God so Pastor bour if you
would uh open in prayer then we'll
launch out into our questions for this
day Father in Heaven we're so thankful
for your word a sure guide in a world
that is so confused amen we ask that you
will be with us in this program that you
will Enlighten our minds strengthen our
voices and bless those who are watching
that the program might bless them and
bring about a change in life we thank
you for hearing our prayer we ask it in
Jesus name amen amen amen amen Pastor it
is perhaps propitious that you did offer
that prayer because this first question
is rather lengthy and it is addressed
principally but not totally to you um a
person has some issue with uh an answer
that you gave some time ago dealing with
the tithe and the storehouse um and so
it's a long question we're not going to
include all of the parts that that he
has here but basically uh walk us
through your reason your rationale your
answer for the tithe the use of the
tithe and what is indeed the storehouse
well the first thing that I want to say
is I love this dear brother that sent
this email uh there were some less than
complimentary things that were said in
it but um I see that he appreciates our
program and uh that he appreciates Yours
Truly um but uh let me just address the
issue of the tithe what I said was that
I believe that we should return our
tithe through the regular channels in
our local church and then it goes from
the local church of course to different
levels to finance the work of God
actually on a global scale uh that is
the way in which the tithe should be uh
administrated um the objection that he
brings up is that uh things in the
church in the church uh the larger
Church
is uh not going the way it's supposed to
be going teachings are not the way
they're supposed to be taught of course
that's not Universal because there are
some churches that are very very
faithful there are other churches that
are not as faithful but you know he kind
of generalizes in uh in his
response and uh my response is that in
spite of the fact that there are places
where the message is not being preached
in places where uh things are not being
being administered the way that they
should be administered it's our
responsibility to return the tithe and
if I can ask uh one of you to please
look for Malachi chapter 3 uh I want us
to read several verses of the condition
of Israel in the days in which the Book
of Malachi was written you know they had
all sorts of serious theological issues
and practices and yet I want you to
notice the counsel that God gave uh
please read uh Malachi 1 and verse
6 all right it says there a son honored
his father and a servant his master if
then I be a father where is my honor and
if I be a master where is my fear said
the Lord of host unto you o priest that
despise my name and you say wherein have
we despise I name okay so what were they
doing questioning God they were
despising God's name now let's go to
chapter 1 and verse 8 and verses 13 and
14 and if he offer the blind for
sacrifice is it not evil and if he offer
the lame and sick isn't it not evil
offered now unto thy Governor will he be
pleased with thee or accept thy person
say the Lord of hosts and verse 13 and
14 13 and 14 he said also so behold what
a weariness is it and ye have snuffed at
it sayeth the Lord of hosts and ye
brought that which was storn and that
lame and the sick thus ye have brought
an offering should I accept this of your
hand said the Lord but cursed be the
deceiver which had in his flock a male
and bow it and sacrificed unto the Lord
a corrupt thing for I am a great king
said the Lord of hosts and my name is
Dreadful among the Heathen wow
what a description of what they were
doing yeah let's see what the priesthood
was doing in chapter 27 and
8 it says for the priest lips should
keep knowledge and they should seek the
law of at his mouth for he is the
messenger of the Lord of host but ye are
departed out of the way you have caused
many to stumble at the law you have
corrupted the Covenant of Levi to the
Lord of
hosts well they weren't teaching very
well were they they were in apostasy and
yet mhm I had you read all those verses
because now we want to read chapter
3 the the passage that deals with the
tithes who wants to read that just
chapter three and around vers 8 through
10 yeah will a man rob God yet ye have
robbed me but you say where have we
robbed thee in tithes and offerings ye
are cursed with a curse for ye have
robbed me even this whole nation bring
ye all the tides into the storehouse and
there may be meat in mine house and
prove me now herewith said the Lord of
hosts if I will not open you the windows
of heaven and pour out you a blessing
that there shall be no room enough to
receive it but the thing is see uh those
who managed the storehouse were offer
lame animals blind animals yes they
weren't teaching God's people the law
they were despising the name of the Lord
and yet what did God say bring the
tithes and the offerings to the
storehouse and so uh God has established
a way in which the tithe is to ad be
administered now let me read you just a
statement from Ellen White here uh about
uh you know when the tithe is mismanaged
this is found in manuscript 3
1890 you have who have been withholding
your means from the cause of God read
the book of Malachi and see what is
spoken there in regard to tithes and
offerings cannot you see that it is not
best under any circumstances to withhold
your tithes and offerings because you
are not in harmony with everything that
your brethren do the tithes and
offerings are not the property of any
man but are to be used in doing a
certain work for God unworthy ministers
may receive some of the means thus
raised but d dare anyone because of this
withhold from the treasury and brave The
Curse Of God I dare not I pay my tithe
gladly and freely saying as did David of
thine own have I given thee a selfish
withholding from God will tend to
poverty in our own Souls Act Your Part
my brethren and sisters God loves you
and he stands at the helm if the
conference business is not managed
according to the order of the Lord that
is the sin of the aing one the Lord will
not hold you responsible for it if you
do what you can to correct the evil so
we have to work to correct evils when
they're they're being performed in the
church uh but then she goes on to say
but do not commit sin yourselves by
withholding from the Lord his own
property see that's the important Point
don't add evil to evil you you need to
correct evil you need to redress the
evil but holding tithe is not part of
your redress you don't get the privilege
of triaging God and triing God's work um
he will take care of that and I think
that's very important right God will
take care of those who are mismanaging
his funds not you because you have some
problem with with the church it's very
very important that our tithe is
something we do we do between our souls
and God not our souls in the conference
now if I can just read one state one
more statement this uh was actually
expressed by Ellen White uh in
California in
1907 some have been dissatisfied and
have said I will no longer pay my tithe
for I have no confidence in the way
things are managed at the heart of the
work but will you rob God because you
think the management of the work is not
right make your complaint plainly and
openly doesn't mean that when we see
things that are wrong for example if uh
if there should be a transgender Elder
who is ordained it doesn't mean we just
keep quiet we say well we're going to
keep the peace no Ellen White makes it
clear she says um make your complaint
plainly and openly in the right spirit
and to the proper ones send in your
petitions for things to be adjusted and
set in order but do not withdraw from
the work of God and prove Unfaithful
because others are not doing right amen
so uh you know this this is God's
counsel and it's for the growth of the
work uh so um that's my response to that
long di
tribe that you didn't read the whole
thing yeah which which contains and and
different people are struck by different
things uh there is a an apologetic that
precedes that uh he talks about willly
white working among the uh black people
in the South uh it wasn't not Willie
Willie never did that it was James Edson
um and she never requested ties to
support his work the the morning star
was was paid for by selling of tools and
selling the book that they used to teach
uh the people um and James Edson and I
don't remember the other Fell's name um
AO OA anyway um they went to the general
conference they got ministerial
credentials so they were licensed
through the general conference they got
their credentials and then they set out
they were paid the handsome salary of $8
a month uh from the tithe because they
were licensed missionaries to the South
so they didn't go around the system they
went through the system and they obeyed
the system They Carried call Porters
with them they sold books along the way
and that's how they managed to finance
themselves not through the uh
misappropriation of tithe money they
they followed the the the letter of the
law and they did what they and Ellen
White who was a prophet of the Lord
which I would put in a different
category of uh you know where we can
actually return our tithe yes uh she
wrote this in letter 96 1911 this is
right before her death yes you ask if I
will accept tithe from you and use it in
the cause of God where most needed in
reply I will say that I shall not refuse
to do this but at the same time I will
tell you that there is a better way it
is better to put confidence in the
Ministers of the conference where you
live live and in the officers of the
church where you worship draw nigh to
your brethren love them with a True
Heart fervently and encourage them to
Bear the responsibilities Faithfully in
the fear of God so El did receive tithe
and uh she used it to help the work in
other places however she never used it
she never authorized it to be used for
building a church or F for paying the
utilities or or or giving to the poor
she always made sure that it was used
for the proclamation of present truth of
the Gospel message supp in other words
it had to go for that so uh she was not
CH channeling the tithe to be used in a
different way than what God prescribes
in his word very very important man very
very important okay I think that we have
addressed that question
adequately and are ready to move on to
Brook who asks is it correct to include
that the Wicked at the time of the end
who have taken the mark of the beast
will be judged in the investigative
judgment uh they claimed to be
Christians and took on the name of of
Christian and many of them actually were
sincere Believers before falling to the
temptation
of the mark of the
beast and then in fact the whole world
at the time of the end will be claiming
to be Christian I know that the
investigative judgment is for anyone who
has ever taken the name of Christian so
the the main point here is whether those
who received the mark of the beast who
perhaps were sincere Believers before
that whether they are going to be
examined in the investigative judgment
because they claim to be
Christian so let me just read a
statement here that we find in great
controversy um this is uh page
4883 uh beginning with those who first
lived upon the Earth our Advocate
presents the cases of each successive
generation and closes with the living so
in other words it begins with Adam goes
chronologically I'm glad it doesn't go
alphabetically it goes
chronologically until those who are
alive at the end uh continues saying
every name is
mentioned every case closely
investigated names are accepted names
rejected when any have sins remaining on
the books books of record unrepented of
and Unforgiven their names will be
blotted out of the Book of Life notice
that their names were in The Book of
Life but it's blotted out in the
investigative judgment and it says and
the record of the good deeds will be
erased from the book of God's
remembrance the Lord declared to to
Moses whatso whosoever has sinned
against me him will I blow out of my
book uh so um will those who receive the
mark of the beast have been judged being
that claim to be Christians because they
have the mark of the beast which is the
observance of Sunday the answer is yes
yes God is going to judge the living at
the end in chronological order just like
he did the Dead uh so uh you know no
matter uh how much they claim to be
Christians uh they will be judged uh and
when probation closes every living
person will be on one side or on the
other side well said well said here's
the 30,000 foot view Revelation chapter
2212 Christ says I'm coming quickly and
my reward is with me right the de facto
position is that when he comes he will
he will know who get the reward and who
does not that case all cases will have
been decided right um everyone who has
ever lived is going to be on one side of
the line or the other right and so no
one's going to be missed no one's going
to be left out no one's going going to
be neglected when he comes it has
already been determined who is going to
get the reward and who will not get the
reward uh and we see that that process
in 1 Thessalonians 4:16 so uh it it is
right to conclude because at the end
every case will be decided and and none
will be left out and illin white does
have a statement in great great
controversy it's a very solemn statement
where she says that many who have have
embraced the message of the third angel
will abandon yes the ranks of God and
join the ranks of the opposition uh so
there will be those even
Adventists who one at one time embraced
The Three Angels messages that are going
to apostatize and she says that there'll
be the worst enemies of their of their
previous Brethren and we are see seeing
little glimpses of that even today
individuals who were solid if we can use
that term Adventist who have sort of
left the rails a little bit and are now
preaching against the church doing harm
to the church uh those kinds of things
so uh prophecy is being fulfilled before
our very eyes Pastor David you have
anything to add to that well yes uh just
to add to what you gentleman have well
said is that it's very clear that in the
last conflict the last decision that God
will give people to make a choice for
truth or for or to Contin the error or
deception there's really just two groups
of people and there is definitely those
who accept the mark of the beast those
who embrace the mark of the beast
regardless of their profession
regardless of what they profess to
believe those who accept that deception
or accept the authority of the Beast are
going to be destroyed are going to be
part or receive the judgments of God and
be part of the those that are rejected
so there's not a third option a way to
to escape you know if you have been uh
if you accept the mark of the beast you
accept the authority of the name of the
Beast you AC the name of of the of the
enemy on your life you will
unfortunately be condemned and this is
what the investigated judgment does it's
uh ex it's to see who can be faithful to
the Lord when that great test of
faithfulness comes who is willing to
stand in you know faithful to what the
Lord said versus what the man or the
Authority or the system implements so
this is where the ultimately the last
part of the Judgment of the investiga
Judgment or the pre judgment takes place
so that there is this test of
faithfulness to God and that's the
ultimate and the final opportunity for
anyone regardless of what they profess
to be either faithful to the Lord and
his word or to follow the the Beast and
The Parables of Jesus m clearly
illustrate this yeah the 10 virgins yes
all of them professed to be followers of
the Lord they all professed being wait
waiting for the bridegroom mhm and yet
five were wise and five were foolish yep
the talents obviously these are
Christians that talents are given to
right but there's one who buries it yeah
you know the seep and the
goats the the goats claim to be
followers of Jesus but they did not
practice practical religion MH uh you
know the man that entered the wedding uh
the wedding Feast without a garment uh
you know the wheat and the tears they
look the same they they're together the
Judgment separates the faithful from the
Unfaithful if I could just read this one
statement which is really sad it's in
great controversy page 608 Ellen White
writes as the storm approaches a large
class yes a large class that's
keyh uh who have professed faith in the
third Angel's message these are
Adventists by the way MH but have not
been Sanctified through obedience to the
truth abandoned their position and join
the ranks of the
opposition by uniting with the world and
partaking of its Spirit they have come
to view matters in nearly the same light
and when the test is brought they are
prepared to choose the easy popular side
men of talent and pleasing address who
once rejoiced in the truth employ their
powers to deceive and mislead Souls they
become the most bitter enemies of their
former Brethren when Sabbath keepers are
brought before the courts to answer for
their faith these apostates are the most
efficient agents of Satan to
misrepresent and accuse them and by
false reports and insinuations to stir
up the rulers against them that is one
of the most tragic and sad statements
that I find in the book The Great
controversy amen so there will will be
Adventists who received the mark of the
beast yeah because they were they became
so worldly that they simply abandoned
the ranks of God's people and joined the
ranks of the opposition yeah I think we
all know of individuals who once were
stars for the Lord who have left the
faith and now preach mightily against
the word of God uh so this is not future
prophecy it's it's it's it's current it
is it is present truth you know it it
remember in the parable B you know that
Christ mentioning there of the
Unfaithful servant it says there that
you know that that Unfaithful servant
who thinks in his heart you know my Lord
delayed his coming and then he starts to
beat his fellow servants and to eat and
drink with the drunken this is the thing
is that you know many today who are
acting and
believing in their hearts that God's
coming is far off is so far away that
they need to you know put their minds
their attention to world and to attain
Riches of this world um those are the
ones that from our own faith are now
raising up against the preaching the
preaching of the truth and the message
for today and many of them are against
the TR teachings of the Bible because it
goes against their own tendency their
own heart and the the Lord speaks of
them you know that they are they're
racing to beat and to you know Smite the
fellow servants and this is what's
happening so yes there will be these
individuals who unfortunately are
walking among us but unfortunately
unless they're converted they will be
partakers of the yes of the sight of the
enemy this is another reason why the
study of the sanctuary is so very
important because we know at the end of
the day of atom if you are not in you
are out if you are not part of those
saved you were lost uh and so this is
the time for us to get our lives right
and to be correct with the Lord because
there is no second chance this this is
it this is a chance that is given to us
well again our time has slipped into
eternity allow me in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our aler
and Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you
again soon byebye and God bless
[Music]